when you think of the most powerful
forces in the world the first things
that come to mind are gravity the strong
nuclear force and black holes but
according to Albert Einstein the most
powerful force in the universe is
actually compounding interest not only
this but he labels compound interest as
that eighth wonder of the world of
course we all know saving and investing
is good but how powerful really is
compound interest
well starting off many YouTube gurus
will tell you that a penny saved is just
a penny saved and so you should focus on
making more money rather than saving
more there is some truth to this as it
would obviously be better to make more
and save more compared to making less
and saving less but you'd be surprised
at how powerful a simple penny can be
when invested in fact if you started
with a simple penny and doubled it every
single day for just one month or a
measly 30 days you would end with a cool
ten point seven million dollars if you
started with one dollar you would
actually be a billionaire by the end now
of course
doubling your money every day for 30
days is nearly impossible but this
illustrates how quickly one can become
wealthy with compound growth and that's
why it's exponentially more important to
grow your money rather than earn more
for instance let's take a look at two
guys with a different investment
philosophies Jeff is super concentrated
on putting in as much as he can into
investments as he thinks the more he put
in the better Elan on the other hand is
more focused on the growth rate and
isn't as concerned about the
contribution Elon contributes a solid
ten thousand dollars per year but Jeff
means business and dopost Ellen's
contribution putting in twenty thousand
dollars per year to do this Jeff puts an
overtime at his job and works really
hard to get a bonus at the end of the
year conversely instead of trying to
contribute more money by working harder
Elon spends his extra time trying to
grow his money faster Elon isn't able to
double Jeff's growth rate of 7% which
isn't work average like Jeff double
Yuans contribution but Elon is able to
increase it by 50% with a growth rate of
10.5% now this doesn't seem like a big
deal as it's only 3.5% higher per year
however after 40 years or basically a
lifetime of work Jeff would have
contributed $800,000 and have a total of
three point nine nine million or right
about four million
would have only contributed half as much
as Jeff at $400,000 but he would
actually have over a million dollars
more than Jeff at 5.07
2 million now what's even more
interesting is that Elon could have just
contributed $10,000 per year for the
first 20 years and then completely
stopped contributing altogether yet he
would still have over four hundred
thousand dollars more than Jeff at four
point four six six million so even more
important that the growth rate is the
investment time period despite
contributing the exact same amount for
40 years trade and maintaining the same
growth rate eelain's contributions over
the first 20 years are worth four point
four six six million while his
contributions over the second 20 years
are only over six hundred thousand or
about 7.5 times less now this is just an
example but it's exactly what happens in
real life we all know Jeff Bezos is the
richest person in the world he currently
has 161 billion dollars and that's after
seeding four percent of Amazon to his
ex-wife or 53 billion dollars worth this
means that if you didn't get divorced he
would be worth two hundred and fourteen
billion today but this isn't because he
gets paid hundreds and millions in stock
every year like many other top ceos in
fact he gets no stock compensation and
he had the same salary since he started
Amazon at eighty one thousand eight
hundred four dollars per year Jeff Bezos
is 56 years old and according to
synchrony Bank the average American in
their 50s has savings worth 67 times
their annual sorry even calling it 10x
this would mean that the average
American making Jeff salary would have
had about $800,000 of the same age given
that Jeff has actually created two
hundred fourteen billion dollars in
total value for him and his family this
means that his investment is worth
twenty six point seven five million
percent higher than the average American
considering that Amazon has only been
around for 26 years you may be thinking
that this means that it was going on
average tens of thousands of percent per
year
but in reality since going public in
1998 Amazon hasn't even had a single
year of four digit growth in fact most
of their growth percentages are in the
double digits and out of the 22 years
shown in this chart for seven years or
about a third of the time they were
actually shrinking Amazon's average
yearly returns since 1998 is not even in
the triple digits it's actually only 78
percent now that's an astonishing early
return but you wouldn't expect a
double-digit return to take a man from a
few hundred thousand to two hundred
billion in less than three decades but
you don't need to get nearly as high
returns to become unbelievably wealthy
in fact Warren Buffett who has averaged
twenty point five percent
illy returns or about double what an
average dedicate investor could get has
managed a mass seventy billion dollars
yet a dedicated investor averaging ten
point two five percent per year doesn't
get anywhere close to thirty five
billion dollars clearly I think we've
established the immense power of
compound interest over time but this
video isn't just about why compound
interest is so powerful on our puny
planet but why it's the most powerful
force in the entire universe so let's
compare it with some of the other
incomprehensible forces of the world
starting with light the speed of light
is a mind-boggling 670 million miles per
hour but in our vast universe the
closest planetary system to us Alpha
Centauri would take four point three six
seven and light years to get to or 25
trillion miles of travel instead if you
just started at 10 miles per hour and
increase your speed by just 10% per day
so 11 miles per hour the second day and
then 12.1 miles per hour the third day
and so on and so forth
in the same 4.36 seven years you would
have traveled on that number or 99
invision Tilian miles that's the same as
one point nine four times ten to the
power of 50 for round trips
but even just looking at the Cova 19
pandemic would tell you everything you
need to know about compound growth those
a date of the first case is heavily
debated it is currently officially
thought to be November 17 to 2019 and in
just the last two hundred 26 days he has
grown from one case to over 10 million
just plugging in a couple of data points
into an exponential regression
calculator we concede that the average
daily growth rate is only 7% at first
glance it wouldn't seem like an issue
but it clearly is not the same ray it
would infect the entire world within the
next 100 days and that's just based on
the known cases of course there are a
variety of reasons why this wouldn't
happen and the growth rate would slow
down but this once again shows the
unlimited power of compound growth or
they're good or bad now this isn't to
say you should go poor your life savings
into Amazon stock tomorrow but you
should be well aware of the power of
compound growth and even if you don't
take advantage of compound growth it is
vital that you avoid compound growth
working against you but that's just what
I think
do you guys to take advantage of
compound growth measure comment that
down below and drop a like if you think
Einstein is right about compound growth
also consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
you